me my name is sanskar in the morning I
work as a software engineer at Bloomberg
where I help create tools for born trade
evaluation
and during the night I maintain an open
source software called Robin
speaking of Robin what is Robin
simply put Robin is a fast async python
web framework with the rest runtime
let's have a look at the current state
of Robin
so Robin is currently hosted on GitHub
it has a BSD 2.0 class it has around
1400 stars on GitHub around 300 000
installs on Pipi
but most importantly it's under active
development
Now by this time I'm pretty sure many of
you must have had this question why
another web framework
what helps Robin actually stand out
so here are some of the key features
firstly it's under active development
second most important feature that it's
not written in just another language
it's written in Rust by the way
it has a multi-sided runtime it has a
very simple API and it's fairly
extensible for you
it's fast and it can serve around 10 000
requests in 0.692 seconds on a dual core
MacBook which is a very old machine if
you want the latest stats you can check
out the latest release on a very strong
machine
uh it is it supports async it has multi
multi-threaded file and directory
serving Dynamic URL routing it supports
middleware websockets
it supports something called constant
requests I'll be explaining you what
that is
but most importantly it's Community
First and truly open source
it's it follows this ideology to an
extent that if you have followed me
somewhere or if you have met me in the
conference you must know that I'm not a
big fan of type support
but Community loves it apparently so
Community shall get what they ask for so
it is a fully typed supported system and
you can use the type safety like you all
know like you all love
now comes the juicy part uh why what is
the robin story uh why did I invest so
much time in making another framework
it was April of 2021 and it was the
final year of my University and my
thesis thesis deadline was approaching
and like any other hard-working student
I was spending all my time exploring
Reddit
sometime around then a big company
decided to introduce rust into the
kernels and that it was filled with this
meme rewriting everything in Rust
and since I was such a dedicated student
I was working on a completely unrelated
project called encryptext that had a
flask backend and during that time I
used to write a lot of node.js in react
and the thing that bothered me about
flask was the lack of async support
so I thought to myself uh you know what
would be cool sanskar if you could
create an async supported flask
and you know what would be cooler if it
would be written in Rush by the way
because during during that time I came
to know that Ryan Dal who's was the
creator of node.js create another
framework called Dino which used rust so
maybe this language is not it's not a
bad choice after all
but the most important questions of the
slide by the name Robin
because if I take care of something
called Robin I help it grow and I help
it develop that automatically makes me
Batman
so if I'm a little slow interviewing the
pis or if I'm not responding on the
community just have a bad signal beside
you and I have a moral obligation to
respond to your question
no okay now coming to the technical part
of the talk let's have a look at the
tradition python web app lifecycle
so usually we have a reverse proxy in
the in the front most part
a web server a reverse proxy is
something like nginx caddy a web server
is an ASCII or a whiskey and finally we
have our web from web framework sitting
at the end called flask Django first API
and so on
so let's have a look at a traditional
flask cap
I like flask a lot and I'm really
inspired by the API and so this is how a
flash cap looks so how many of you folks
know how to create a very basic flask
app
all right perfect so you import the
flask class from the app you initialize
the uh you initialize the app and you
add some decorators to add the routes
so this is how Robin's API look you
import Robin uh from the robin module
you initialize it and you create routes
for it
the I have made some changes in the API
that I felt would make it more useful
and more friendlier according to my
experience for example you don't have an
app.rout method you have an
app.getapp.post and so on methods to
define the routes for your application
and also one of another reason for me uh
to create an API that was so similar to
flask was to reduce the learning curve
to explore a new framework because most
of us are already familiar with these
Frameworks and writing a very different
framework would be a very big commitment
for everyone
so this is how it looks like now let's
have a look at the server aspect of the
code
a question to the audience how many of
us know uh whatever whiskey or an ASCII
is
okay
so this is a code snippet of a very
basic whiskey a whiskey stands for web
server Gateway interface the reason why
uh whiskey were created I think 20 years
back was because there were so many web
Frameworks at the time but there was no
standard to actually serve them and it
was getting very hard for the frame
framework maintenance to serve the
application
so it was released in pep 333 if you
folks want to check it out
this allowed the framework maintainers
to focus on the to on the routing side
and the execution side where the whiskey
would take care of all the dirty Parts
like handling HTTP requests handling the
response for you so on
have a lot of benefits but for Robin you
do not require an ASCII server
uh Robin comes with a coupled ASCII
server so it is one of the reason that
makes it much faster than everyone else
so this is how a life cycle of an Robin
app would look it is as simple as
writing python3 app.py you do not have
to decide between choosing the right
whiskey or an ASCII server so no G
unicorn no UV coin no style it you just
tried
python3app.py you put it behind a
reverse proxy and you have your working
server
now let us have a look at the
architecture to have a sense of what
actually is happening
first of all uh we have a worker event
cycle that basically does all the heavy
lifting for you this part manages the
runtime it passes all the instruction to
the rust code and then spawns a thread
pool in the middle
so when we type the command python
app.py
the python code is converted to rust
objects as you can see here
and then it is populated in a thread
safe
thread safe router
and when the incoming requests uh come
to the router the router gets the rest
object from the mapping passes it in a
thread pool depending on if it's a sync
function or an async function and then
the response is executed and then
returned back as a response
but to scale it to even more extent we
have a TCP socket that's listening to
the request and we can have multiple
processes as well as multiple workers
now so all this all the thing that I
explained earlier can be scaled across
multiple cores of your machine
so this is also another reason why robin
is faster compared to other Frameworks
in the market
now this feature called const request
optimization for the lack of a better
name was released a week back
so I realized that the encircled part is
very guilt dependent how many of you
know what a kill is
okay so Gale is basically a global
interpreter lock which in Python
accounts to the slow performance
for example it's us some reason for the
slower performance because it doesn't
allow like a true multi-threaded
experience so for simple things like
serving let's say hello world or serving
a Json schema acquiring and releasing
Guild would be a big overhead so we
realized what would it wouldn't it be
cool if it would just be eliminated and
the rest we we were able to serve rust
uh like the response directly from the
rust side without ever invoking the
python object
so these are different ways I could
think of on writing hello world in
Python and serving so we have S strings
Dynamic strings
uh strings that are converted on the
flat
so I went on and disassembled this code
and this is how python looks in assembly
on a closer inspection you see that only
a constant is loaded before a return
value is returned
so all of this is replicated in all the
patterns below
so how automatic const request
optimization works is that it sees the
assembly it pre-computes the value
stores it in the uh thread safe router
and without ever like acquiring or
releasing a lock it serves the response
back to you
so automatic constant request
optimization is still under work whereas
the constant request optimization is
already present in version 17.0 so this
was just too cool for me to not just
show off and make you for folks feel
excited for 17.1
coming to the usage you can simply do a
pip install Robin or install it via
contact you do not need to have rust
installed on your machine
um
now we have a little feature showcase to
get you folks excited
so Robin for supports synchronous
functions because
many libraries still have synchronous
functions and
as much as I wanted to make it fully
async uh we need synchronous support
because some Library maintainers uh
either can't upgrade the libraries or
don't want to it's a very hot topic and
we don't want to start a debate here
it obviously supports async function
because it was one of the core reasons
behind Robin's origin
and I was a react developer as well and
it always bothered me that I was unable
to serve react applications from a flask
app very easily so I created a way to
add sub routes and you can serve
multiple react application on a single
server
using the add directory method
we have static file serving which is uh
much faster than the native python file
serving so if you ever want to serve
like large files on a machine on on your
web server it will be much faster than
using the native python way
we have Dynamic URL routing so if you
want to have route parameters in your
route you can use it like that
so it it also scales across multiple
cores so you can scale it as multiple
workers as well as multiple processes if
you have any restriction on the number
of threads that you can use on your your
on your server
uh we have middle base for logging for
authentication and we all love
middlewares basically yes we
we support web sockets
so
um your real-time applications are also
supported in Robin
constant requests
and much more at the GitHub repo
now if you folks are still not excited
we have the performance comparison
but a PSA that this comparison is not to
demean any framework or the people
associated with the framework the these
Frameworks are the reason why I got
involved in the python ecosystem
but here you go so this is a comparison
between flask fast API Django Robin on
one worker and Robin on five hookers so
as you can see flask took around five
seconds to serve 10 000 requests uh fast
API took four seconds Django took 13. uh
I mean Django with G unicorn to 13.
Robin on a single worker took 1.8
seconds whereas on a five with five
workers that was the maximum workers
that could be allocated on my dual core
machine it took only 0.69 seconds to
serve 10 000 requests
now seeing what's in plan for Robin for
the future
I want to make it more performant add
open API integration because it is a
better way to write documentation I add
pedantic support Implement automatic
const request optimization orm supports
improve the plug-in ecosystem better
documentation
prove the web sockets
and I came to realize in this conference
that people want to add template support
like ginger templates so to support the
inside templates with Robin
make graphql integration with strawberry
and my I came to came to also realize
that no not many people are available on
Jitter and the main reason to have a
community communication platform was to
make it more accessible so we'll be
migrating the community to Discord
and most importantly
try to increase the community
involvement
uh speaking of the community
join our community if you are interested
on making PRS doing reviews sponsoring
or if you are just curious here is the
link to the community
and special thanks to the people who are
already there the sponsors the
contributors without without you folks
it wouldn't have been possible
so here are some of the important links
we have the GitHub link the Pi Pi link
the website the docs link
and yeah
star Robin on GitHub and let me know if
you have any questions